he was in three Super Bowls now he's
working for NBC Terry McCauley the
former football official and he joins us
now Terry thanks for joining us I'm a
little confused still with the helmet
rule but I don't know how it works with
officials when there's a new rule do you
over call during the preseason and then
maybe it subsides a little bit during
the regular season I think as a general
concept yes that's exactly what happens
because everybody wants to get a feel
for what the exact guidance is going
into week one so if you don't call it
then maybe the play gets addressed in
review and maybe it doesn't during the
week so but if you do then then there's
there should be a definitive statement
from the league office yes this is what
we want or no this is what we don't want
and it makes sense for us and for the
players and the coaches as well all
right simplify this or at least put it
in layman's terms of the new helmet rule
what should we be looking for right now
what we've been told is is when the
player lowers his head and establishes
some type of linear posture and and then
initiates and makes contact with his
helmet to any part of the opponent's
body that's a foul
the term forcible is not use the term
punishing is not used
it's just that posture that the player
takes in attacking the opponent so it's
fairly basic but you know you're they're
also telling us that there we now want
the officials to read intent
yeah and that's something we rarely if
ever have done mmm
so that adds a little bit to it I will
say that if you look at the two plays
where Walt announced illegal use of the
helmet I think that's exactly what they
want I think that was a pretty good
indicator of what the league wants out
of the game and if that's what we're
getting if we can get that consistently
I think by week one of the regular
season they'll they'll have it down how
would you explain or call or maybe not
call if Tom Brady on a quarterback sneak
lowers his head and is leading with his
helmet
and not looking up is that a flag Abul
offense it's not and they've told us
specifically that quarterback sneaks
they're not lowering their head to make
contact with an opponent they're
lowering their head to protect
themselves and to gain yardage and it's
it they're saying it's not a foul okay I
think the difference is and and and what
I saw a lot over the years where Cam
Newton does the RPO and he established
itself as a runner going into the line
that's a different story I think that's
something that would be a foul as
opposed to the quarterback snake that
we're used to saying but is this it just
feels like you know you just said you
have to be able to judge intent yeah
this is the toughest job we have in
sports Terry
it's so fast it's real time and you're
trying to judge intent
I just think that there the degree of
difficulty on NFL officials is ratcheted
up it's just too high it really is it is
but it's it's with regard to player
safety and I think whatever we have to
do to make this game safer and and they
put out some videos with with the head
coaches doing coaching techniques to get
this out of the game I think once once
those really take hold
you're not even to see players do this
anymore they're good they're gonna
they're gonna play the game with proper
technique and not put the officials in
in in that position very often and it's
really combined effort from coaches
players and officiating to get this
right yeah and I go back to and I've
said this before I was told a couple of
years ago that the NFL wants to look at
how rugby is played and how tackles are
made and how you don't use your helmet
they don't have helmets you you don't
lead with your head can the NFL still be
the NFL by adopting more of what happens
in rugby I think so and I think last
night as I was watching the game we saw
some terrific big hits shoulder to chest
shoulder to shoulder shoulder back
whatever that separate that did exactly
what the defenders wanted to do legally
and it was still
great exciting play that you know fans
go you know the excitement of that big
hit and it's legal and you're not you're
not putting a head and neck injury and
into play and it's I think we can get
there and I think we have to get there
he's Terry McCauley the former football
official in the NFL now working with NBC
with their telecast joining us Dan
Patrick show yeah that's another thing
where you have intent and you're trying
to figure out what intent is I I also
bring this up to people having been on
the sidelines for a game and here you
are officiating just the sounds of the
crashes that you have is there a tackle
that you remember on just the noise
itself yeah there have me and I couldn't
point to one specifically but you know
being there you actually see it setting
up and you're you just almost cringe to
yourself what's about to happen and then
it does and you just go oh and it's
almost hard to keep officiating because
because yours just like fans you want to
react to that great huge hit you know
Ray Lewis was one that you knew it was
coming and you really felt bad for the
guy that was about to get hit and he had
more than more than more than a few that
I saw what's the hardest you ever got
hit wrong again I really never got hit I
got knocked down for the first time last
year on an interception just we were in
the wrong place at the wrong time and
and but that was really yet I as a
referee I'm kind of on the periphery so
it just I I was I was lucky until that
one one little incident the new kickoff
rule mm-hmm what do you think you know
we didn't see much of it last night but
I I loved it I spent a lot of time
talking to Jerry Rosberg the great
special teams coach for Baltimore who
was a big part of developing this I mean
officiating important didn't didn't
develop this and you know competition he
had a lot to do with but the special
teams coaches did and and it's a great
next step because I had moved to the
point where I felt kickoffs needed to go
away these massive collisions that we
were seeing at both the college and the
NFL level
nobody did anything wrong but the chance
of severe head neck injury was was was
significantly higher so something had to
be done and I think this is a great step
and I think as it develops you know we
didn't see it last night but I think the
advantage is a little bit to the
receiving team so it sets up is maybe a
more exciting play if there is a return
with less chance of injury and if you
have the big leg like we saw last night
several times and it's kicked out of the
end zone
then there's almost no chance of injury
and we start the ball on the 25-yard
line
so I think it's a great next step I
think there's there's things talking to
Jerry but that the coaches have to
figure out the officials have to figure
out how to mechanically deal with the
double-team blocks and the illegal wedge
blocks but but overall I think the
committee the competition committee did
a great job protecting players with with
this change there was a play last night
the Ravens tight end had the ball
dislodged from him and in the end zone
and I think you even said they should
have called a penalty on that for a
defenseless receiver no they did call
once again okay so they did call you you
agreed with that call no no and in real
time those those do get missed I mean
that's that's just you know you see that
bang-bang play in real time and it
appears that he's in to the head and
neck area and in slow motion replay well
he just didn't quite get there and and
but that is kind of the the philosophy
it's not when in doubt but if it's that
close then then then we'll throw the
flag to protect the players and and it
is week one and I think there was just
they just made a mistake
I think Walt announced just an
unnecessary roughness al he did you but
kind of led us all into the wrong
direction that it maybe it was the new
rule because we didn't get enough
information on the announcement but as
we looked at it more and he didn't make
the same announcement we did deal with
it as a as a defenseless player and
there just wasn't forcible contact at
the head and neck area same same with
the play later in the game as well but
also Terry I'm trying to figure out
defenseless receiver if I'm in
enzone I'm a defensive back and you go
up for the ball mm-hmm I'm not allowed
to hit you oh absolutely but you just
can't make forcible contact of a head
neck area
okay so that's it last night so that
wasn't a foul so defenseless receiver is
only if I go up top correct yeah well
that and one other thing if you lead
with the crown of your helmet go into a
defense or that's also so that's it
that's okay that clears that up because
I was trying to figure this out of if
I'm a defense by the way are we ever
gonna give the defense rules in their
favor I'm personally a big fan of
defensive football I don't like the
67-68
that we see in college football a lot
these days but you know they they do
pretty well in the NFL but we've taken
away everything Terry we've taken away
you can't you know a head slap and the
five-yard penalty can't put your hands
on somebody
well people generally like scoring and I
do think they the the rules tend to
favor the often well they do they do I
do know that that they they do try to
keep some balance I mean they they're
not you know college college is way out
of whack with with protecting the
offense they do things that I just
cringed that the defense isn't allowed
to do but but the NFL is a little better
in maintaining that balance I think do
you ever have players who tried to warm
up to you players were great I mean
they're out there doing their job I I
tell people you have the exceptions that
were people that were difficult to deal
with but as a general rule 99.9 percent
you'd love them to be your next-door
neighbor I mean they're just good people
especially offensive line I was always a
person thing of offensive lineman I I
think I think they make the whole game I
mean as certainly as a referee in my
position if I had a great offensive line
particularly a great left tackle if I
really watched a lot my it was the
easiest day I ever had my two favorites
were Jonathan Ogden and Orlando pace if
I had them it was they were never going
to commit a foul and they really did
offensive in was never going to beat him
and him hit the quarterback that was
supposed to protect so it was just a
great day when I had people like that
who talked to you the most Mark Brunell
okay and and I as a referee I I don't go
looking for conversations so they had to
come to me Mark Brunell was incredibly
personable
back in his day just again just one of
those good guys out there having fun and
playing a little football alright who
was a jerk to you retired now Terry I am
I mean there were some that are more
intense and that that you didn't didn't
didn't really want to deal with first
and in an emotional situation absolutely
and it just rolls off and that's one of
things you learn early be in the NFL how
to handle those because they the players
at that emotional level they want to be
managed they don't want to do something
that would hurt their team so we try to
manage that emotion and it may be just a
stern look it may be you're talking to
and maybe a stern talking-to and unless
it really is over the top and then they
get a flag but they invariably when that
happened and you got them back to plays
later they tapped you on the butt and
say sorry arrest I mean and that's the
kind of people they that we were really
dealing with there were the rare
exceptions that may be in a book someday
I'll I'll mention who those they were
but they I'm telling you and it's just
like off the field the the the people
there are the rare exceptions that make
mistakes and do things they shouldn't do
but the vast majority like I said and
it's my favorite line you really love to
have them as your next-door neighbor
ever been confronted by a fan in
everyday life no in fact I guess it was
my style in in and walking the streets
or in the airports or whatever I think I
was only recognized in public maybe half
a dozen times over over a 17 year of
careers of referee so because my style
was you know I didn't want to be on TV a
lot just here's what we got and we're
gonna get the plate ball going again and
and move on so I didn't present you know
that public figure that people see all
the time and recognized but if you were
going to do this again and just starting
out would you then work on your arms to
have them more like Ed Hochuli well
everybody has their stick I I guess and
that that area seems to be kind of the
way everybody's going mine was a little
different and and I don't think it would
have worked for me hey I wish you wish
you well good luck with the telecast and
joining a great team so have fun
absolutely thanks for having me Dan and
Greg great job on yourself alright Terry
McCauley the NBC sports rules official
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]